bonjour à tous aujourd'hui va parler des
écrans pliables on a beaucoup parlé avec
samsung on va en parler avec plein
d'autres parce que vous allez voir que
son sujet très intéressant quelque chose
qui va vraiment se développer
on va parler aujourd'hui des écrans
pliables de huawei et sony va maintenant
les écrans pliables c'est vraiment le
sujet le sujet de 2018 parce qu'on voit
qu'effectivement 2010 est la tendance
s'était les écrans bord à bord les très
grands écrans en a 18 9e
là on a fondu 19/9 mais au delà
d'agrandir toujours l'écran alors arrivé
sur une nouvelle techno sur ses écrans
pliables
on sait aujourd'hui que la technologie
des écrans pliables quelque chose qui
existe
on a déjà vu sur différents proto que ce
soit sur lenovo la vue sur lg ocs
s'était présenté un écran enroulable ya
beaucoup de choses qui vont arriver dans
ce sens et vous allez voir on en parle
beaucoup en 2018 c'est des produits qui
vont arriver d'ici très peu de temps
peut-être fin 2018 très probablement en
tout cas 2019 il ya beaucoup de
personnes sont dans la course alors y'a
samsung effectivement avec son galaxy s
qui fait parler de lui depuis 2011 à
voir on a beaucoup entendu parler c'est
un petit peu l'arlésienne c'est le prix
dont tout le monde parle et que personne
ne voit et qu'on attend et on se demande
même si un jour il finira par arriver
mais oui très clairement ces choses là
vont arriver elles vont vraiment nous
surprendre et avoir des smartphones
nouvelle génération d'ici quelques
années avec des écrans pliables alors on
va parler très très prochainement des
iphones pliable qui arriveront donc
abonnez vous restez connectés parce que
vous allez voir c'est un sujet qu'on va
suivre de très près et pour l'instant on
a concentré aujourd'hui sur le cas de
huawei parce que huawei en la personne
de richard ue qui est le patron la
division grand public de voir où et a
effectivement confirmé qu'il travaillait
très activement sur un smartphone avec
un écran pliable que pour l'instant il
avait un prototype fonctionnel mais que
bon il ya encore un petit peu de table
parce que en réalité leurs robes
prototype cette baisse de bouquins qui
va se plier avec un écran sauf
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas un écran sont
deux écrans avec une charnière au centre
mais que à terme il n'y aura plus qu'un
seul écran pliable qu'il leur faut
effectivement encore travailler pour
rendre écrans toujours plus flexibles et
pour avoir un produit qui est toujours
mieux fini d'un point de vue général un
point de vue global donc aurait
effectivement que ses smartphones
filiales vont arriver et ça plus
rapidement qu'on peut le penser
alors à l'origine de tout ça on a un
brevet et elle est couverte par le site
l'escaut digital qui nous annonce un
petit peu la couleur et qu'il nous
montre à quoi pourra ressembler le
smartphone avec un écran pliable de wade
est un brevet a été déposé en septembre
2007 et qui a été publié le 29 mars 2018
auprès de l'organisation mondiale de la
propriété intellectuelle alors qu'est ce
qu'on voit quand on regarde ce brevet on
voit effectivement un espèce de bouquins
un bouquin qui va se payer avec un écran
central donc on imagine que son
smartphone une fois fermé il sera comme
ça donc là au milieu en écran là vous
avez ma prise de notes
vous arrivez à brescia nous déchiffrer
bon courage c'est que vous savez lire le
hiéroglyphe la question qui se pose
maintenant c'est de se dire vous avez un
écran central
une fois fermée qu'est ce que vous avez
à l'extérieur vous n'avez rien donc en
réalité vous avez l'esprit de tablettes
qui se déplie mais si on parle de
smartphones on a forcément parlé quelque
chose qui rentre dans la poche donc
quelque chose qui se plie donc qu'est-ce
que vous allez avoir un avant ici un
autre écran peut-être ou alors est-ce
que votre écran plat va se plier dans
les deux sens comme ça et comme ça et là
ça me fait penser un peu aux produits de
zte l'axone m que je vous ai présenté au
mois de janvier dernier au cs de las
vegas qui une fois comme ça vous avez un
écran lorsque vous ouvrez vous avez un
deuxième écran dans son deux écrans avec
un espace aux milieux et espèces de
charnière vous avez plusieurs
possibilités soit avoir d'un côté un
écran qui fonctionne seul hélas rien du
tout soit un seul et même grand écran ça
nous fait un peu comme espèce de
tablettes soit ici deux fois le même
écran
bon il ya différentes possibilités qui
peuvent être vus en tout cas là dessus
mais ça pose en tout cas une question
très intéressante
à quoi vont ressembler ces écrans
pliables comment est ce qu'ils seront
les plus fonctionnels parce que a priori
samsung le prendrais dans l'autre sens
plutôt à la verticale ça serait comme
une espèce de canard c'est comme les
téléphones à clapet qu'on avait à
l'époque c'est à dire votre grand écran
on vous le refermer donc on peut
imaginer d'avoir un autre petit écran ce
temps le dessus comme on avait pour vous
dire vous avez un appel de telles
personnes vous avez un message de telles
personnes
bon il ya encore plein de choses à mon
avis qu'on ne connaît pas aujourd'hui
qui se dévoileront petit à petit mais en
tout cas ce qu'on voit est ce qui est
super intéressant c'est que les gros
constructeurs comme huawei comme samsung
comme lenovo et bientôt comme apple se
penche dès aujourd'hui sur la question
des écrans pliables des smartphones avec
des écrans pliables des choses toujours
plus modulable qui vont rentrer sur les
formats encore plus petit qui une fois
ouvertes auront le format d'une petite
tablette en tout cas d'une fable est en
plus le super intéressant là dessus
c'est que huawei est le numéro trois
mondial de la téléphonie mobile
vous avez apple et samsung sont toujours
un petit peu au coude à coude un coup
c'est dans le première course avec le
premier ça dépend effectivement du mois
ça dépend du produit qui est annoncé sa
détente pas mal de choses ce matin petit
peu cette place un son toujours un petit
peu très très serré et huawei et le
troisième avec en tout cas une part de
marché de l'ordre de 10
pour cent donc il arrive vraiment en
force et l'intérêt pour moi oui c'est
d'être premier d'être leader de capable
de surprendre avec un écran pliable
avant tout le monde
rien ne dit qu'ils vont être les
premiers peut-être samsung peut-être
lenovo apple très clairement ils
arriveront beaucoup plus tard donc ils
vont laisser un petit peu le temps aux
autres de se casser les dents sur le
marché et devancer de marché de mur et
s'il est intéressant mais en attendant
ce qui est sûr c'est que huawei une
vraie carte à jouer là dessus pour
proposer un produit innovant
révolutionnaire un petit peu avant tout
le monde qui de apple
huawei lenovo motorola samsung et tous
les autres seront le premier soral
premier qui sera le grand champion à
sortir en premier son smartphone avec un
écran pliable d'ailleurs dit moi vous ce
que vous en pensez en commentaire à quoi
devrait ressembler un smartphone avec un
écran pliable plutôt une forme de
bouquins plan quelque chose qui se
plient à la verticale je sais pas si mon
petit canard vous permet de vous pour
acheter
et d'imaginer ce que pourrait être un
écran pliable dans son scaphandre vous
ne marquez tout ça en commentaire bien
évidemment on va en discuter ensemble
restez connectés parce que ça c'est des
studios tombe a beaucoup parlé à
l'avenir vous allez voir c'est chose de
super intéressant et de super
passionnant merci à vous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo comme d'alves et a blessé
des jolies pousse à vous abonner à
marquer tout ce que vous voulez en
commentaire à me joindre sur twitter
facebook snapshot instagram que 16 que
sa rivale google+ bouvelle plus est ce
que vous êtes sur google+ est ce qu'il
ya des gens sans nouvelles plus je suis
pas sûr
en attendant merci à vous vous marquez
tout ça je donne rendez vous très
bientôt sur les sages
je vous embrasse et d'ici là portez vous
bien
[Musique]